In the previous
video, we focused
on how the corporation is
changing in the United States.
But what about corporations
around the world?
Turns out there's quite
a bit of variation
both across countries
and over time.
So let's take a
brief tour of what's
happening in other places.
Corporations in the United
Kingdom, Canada, Australia
tend to follow the US model of
putting shareholder value very
high in their priorities.
But they haven't
gone quite as far.
For example, CEOs aren't paid
as much in those countries
as in the United States.
So the gap between CEO
pay and average worker pay
isn't nearly as much as we
have in the United States.
But some other countries, like
Germany and Norway and Sweden,
have tended to take much more
of a multiple stakeholder
view of the firm and
its responsibilities.
We can best see this
as the way companies
are organized in Germany.
So let's take a look at Germany.
In Germany, the
board of supervisors,
equivalent to boards of
directors in the United States,
is made up of large
representatives
of large financial institutions
and representatives
of employees, sometimes equal
numbers and sometimes different
percentages.
But employees play a role
in corporate governance
directly in Germany.
At the workplace level, there
are consultative bodies called
works councils, elected bodies
elected by blue collar workers,
production workers, white
collar workers, managers,
and supervisors, all
there to provide advice
to the company on its human
resource and employment
practices.
And in fact, the company has
to listen to the works council
when it makes changes
in employment policies.
Then corporations are also
very active in training,
working together at the original
level with vocational schools
and with labor to build
apprenticeship programs so
that they have an
adequate supply of workers
for today's economy and
for tomorrow's technology
and economy.
So in Germany and in
European countries,
you tend to see much more
of the corporation taking
a responsible role for
these kinds of activities.
Let's look at another
example, Japan.
Japan has corporate boards that
have basically three groups.
First, they have the
investors, the banks.
Secondly, they have suppliers
and the network of suppliers
that firms have long
term relationships with.
And third, they have internal
corporate executives.
And in fact, often the
most influential executive
in Japanese corporations
sitting on these boards
is the human resource executive.
And that's one of
the reasons why
we see longer term
employment security
part of the Japanese tradition.
We see much more investment
in training and development
of employees from within.
Now these practices
are changing.
Japan's economy
has been struggling
to adapt to a more
innovative, flexible economy.
And so some corporations open
to international competition
have moved more toward the
American model in recent years.
So nothing is cut in stone.
Changes happen from time to
time as the economy changes.
Here's another example, Korea,
also in the throes of change.
Korea also has a long history
of very large corporations, very
paternalistic, long term
employment security.
But as Korea has made
a very strong effort
to become more flexible,
more innovative,
some of these
traditions are changing.
And that's led to
lots of conflict
over the appropriate role
of the corporation in Korea.
So there is a country that
is in the throes of change.
We'll have to wait and
see how it plays out.
Some companies in
various countries
have charted their own
course, independent of what
the government is doing.
For example in Brazil,
there's a very famous company
called Semco that in the
1980s, a new CEO took over
by the name of Richard Semler.
And he helped grow that
company from about $2 million
in revenue to over $200
million in about a decade.
And what did he do?
He said let's democratize
the organization.
Let's let workers
shape their own jobs.
help us to figure out
how we can expand
into new industries
and diversify this
company and become
part of the world economy.
And in fact he's been
recognized for his leadership
and his vision by the
World Economic Forum, which
described him and gave
him an award as one
of the global
leaders of tomorrow.
Likewise in Finland, a
company by the name of Nokia,
known well in the
telecommunications industry
and in the phone business, had
a very difficult time adjusting
to changes in its markets.
And so it's had to restructure
and lay off a lot of workers.
But as it did so,
it decided that it
would allow workers to take
some of the product development
ideas that they had been working
on and some of their own ideas
for new directions
for the company
and start their own companies.
And they would support
these employees
during this transition period.
So you can see
that companies can
shape their own corporate
governance arrangements, even
within a national government.
Well, what can we learn
from this very quick survey
around the world
of how corporations
structure themselves?
I think there are two lessons.
First, there's no one best way.
The American mantra of
profits over everything else
isn't necessarily
copied around the world.
There are different approaches.
And the second
thing to recognize
is that these all have to
adapt over time to changes
in the economy, to changes
in the workplace issues
that we are facing.
And so we can change our
corporate governance policies,
even within a country,
when necessary.
And so I think
this is good news.
It means there is
no one best model.
It means that we
can adapt over time.
And it means that we have some
choice over how we structure
the role of the corporation in
response to its shareholders
and other stakeholders
in society.
So let's get on with
thinking about what
role do we want the
corporation in our society
to play today and tomorrow.